[Music]
welcome back you can stay with me
word for word because you already know
what i'm going to say welcome back to
careful boys everybody we are currently
off the record
the eye roll is very good
so this is the part two of how did we
meet our significant other and how do we
talk to them and the whole build up of
it because not everybody got to say say
and this is juicy juice i thought the
whole thing was how did you
[ __ ] ask yourself no
no that's what it was that's what you
changed it to take another prompt
for later we were like yo how did you
ask the girl i was
15
superman
i already told my story the original
question is how did you first ask your
girl out so we'll go with anthony in the
next because we know someone dies in
ryan's story yeah so we'll say that for
the end yeah because that is truly the
end could she go die i got to prepare
the death certificate
let's go with anthony and fernies all
right so it's debatable on like who made
the first move apparently but you know
because this is like you know on the
record this is my record so i'm gonna
say my part
um so with nina she was on my old uh
college dance team cadc
uh so i would like go back you know as
an alumni and stuff and like choreograph
and blah blah so like i knew of her she
knew of me scope out the youngins the
new me old enough for kissing out for
too long
damn it that worked too well good dude
you're good you're gonna find a lot of
these 13 for 13.
and then there was a there was a moment
where you know it was
you know i guess i guess is what she
says i slam the dms you know what i mean
um
on facebook facebook messenger right and
it was her birthday give her a poke so i
wanted to i wanted
that's what they do on facebook
nothing and i just wish her happy
birthday i said something like you know
like happy birthday and maybe i was a
little more forward than that i was just
like happy birthday you know it's like
it's really cool to see you from time to
time or like i look forward to like me
all your wishes come true dick pic
anyways um so so i just left it at that
you know and i was like oh okay cool and
that just kind of like you know broke
that barrier but that was it it was just
a birthday thing
um and that wasn't until later
uh that i was going to disney and she
worked at disneyland at the time she was
like dancing the parades and [ __ ] like
that
um and then i went to disneyland usually
when i go to disneyland i you know in
the dance community there's a lot of
people that we know that like work there
right so like oftentimes people like
swipe you in or or different things like
that like
you know
rarely try to pay full price when you go
to disneyland you're always trying to
hit somebody up right
so when i got in i got signed in uh by
my homie and then from there i was still
hitting up different people i was like
yo you performing today blah blah and
then so i also messaged her in the dms
and i was just like hey you know i'm a
digital blah blah and i tried to in my
mind i was trying to rationalize it like
oh i hit up like three different people
when really i didn't give a [ __ ] she
doesn't [ __ ] know yeah but i i just
you know i hit her up she's like oh you
should have let me know like i would
have signed you in or whatever they're
right but this is like my maybe like
third interaction with her like very
very short and shallow so i was also
like i i wouldn't just hit you up to ask
you to sign me in you know blah blah
and that was kind of nice a little
flirtational we chatted my phone was
about to die i was like oh you should
stay in my room my phone's about to die
it was
it's light flirting very light
later on though
[ __ ] i can't believe i'm saying the
story out here um later on though uh
apparently we had a mutual friend who
was on the uh who was on the team during
my time but who was dancing with her at
disneyland and working there right she
there was a cadc party that was going on
in irvine at some point so she had asked
our mutual friend to invite me to this
party i didn't know that she was
oh that's what i'm saying she made it
she made a strong move y'all just signed
the dm's wishing to have birthdays and
poking people you know she was making a
strong blue that's why i'm like she
really made the move she's like they
call me mcbee
she's like anthony how old are you
so
so so he invites me to this party i'm
like yeah cool i'll show it to this
party you know what i mean and i go to
this party and she's there obviously so
it's like cool we you know there's a lot
of people there
everybody's drinking doing random stuff
right
and then um
no names no names please but my
ex-girlfriend shows up because she was
also part of my dance team right and i
and i'm i'm at coother i'm super cool
with her you know what i mean like all
amicable stuff like that um and i hadn't
seen her for a long time so it ends up
we end up chopping it up at this party
and then because we're both alumni me
and my ex it was just kind of like oh
you you know what i mean like you're
going to balance on the balance too so
we end up leaving the party together
nothing happens or anything like that it
was just an excuse to balance yeah but
it just looks yeah just literally it
looks demotivating for that she later
tells me that i [ __ ] like crushed her
yeah totally crushed her she also knew
you're with the other chick before yeah
yeah because we were all from the same
team and stuff like that again nothing
happened but it was just more like she
you know she like sneakily tried to get
me there but then i ended up leaving
with my ex so yeah so that happened and
then so that kind of like you know
settled down for a little bit but then
luckily i you know still like
messaging her from time to time the dms
and then from there i think it was uh
finally that i was you know just asking
her out and whatnot
i asked her out we go on our first date
i take it to like laguna beach or
something like that because i was like
you know in the oc area take it to the
spot too let's just go eat we like fly
kite it's all cute and [ __ ] like that
she's being you're a cute man
you're a cute man you're a cute this is
like little love souvenirs shop by the
beach and stuff had a kite and i was
like yo you have a fly kite and she was
like no that's wholesome that's dope
he's never flown a kite i'm not even
[ __ ] i'm not saying [ __ ] i'm just
that's don't be defensive about it we're
just like wow i've never heard you don't
go like hey you ever do anal she's like
no and then you go
there's just a couple of anal beads at
the zoo
so so that that yeah
i asked her out that was our first day
we're in laguna beach uh i asked her if
she would have flown a kite she's like
no so we ended up going into the store i
buy this blue kite for like 14 bucks um
and i guess the semi-cute thing about it
is that uh we still have that kite
yeah that's cute you guys go fly it no
we never flew it a second time but we
just haven't i feel like it's going to
be one of those things that ends up
showing in like at like the wedding or
something you know what i mean are you
gonna uh hang it in your house is it
hung in your house or it's collecting
dust in the corner of a closet no that's
honestly awesome because on because
because she held that kite when they
first did anal
she penetrated anthony though that's
what it was yeah yeah yeah you're very
romantic i still have the same condom
that we [ __ ] with
he's like it's like you've never been
cutting that he
she flies the guy he's like that's not
all there is to kiting
me not do not use this moment right now
to [ __ ] bastard has my kite i got
this one
i've been holding on down for like eight
years do not [ __ ] up my kite okay i have
to clean out my [ __ ] to flag shut the
[ __ ] up
it is that innocent and pure blue kite
blue cut i'm gonna look out for it can
we move on the neck already goddamn man
that's why i don't wanna [ __ ] tell
you my [ __ ]
i don't know what was going on
dude i'm gonna go with you
shut the [ __ ] up you almost made it
though we'll go out there that's a
really cute story i thought it was great
so what did you first do hale um never
i've never done an anal actually before
can't say i have uh you never tuck it in
your butt you're gonna love the kite
element of italy
so my our story goes all the way back to
like sophomore year of high school high
school high school yeah whoa how old are
you i'm 29.
old enough for kisses low-key i was too
scared for kisses at that point your boy
was scared
he's gonna be for [ __ ] eight and a
half minutes
you started to think the sound appears
nick's just like i was ready
gotta be ready you gotta be ready so
anyway it goes back to sophomore year
you guys have been together 14 years 13
years we've been together for 12 years
12 years ago you're the longest couple
here oh no bartender they probably got
more yeah but he's the old ass
[ __ ]
but
today's video is brought to you by
audible i love audible man i've been uh
so i'm really close to finishing the
book psychology of money but my favorite
thing about it isn't just for like road
trips like obviously it's super awesome
people just zone in and learn during
like a three four hour car ride but what
i like that's so convenient about the
audible app it's the first thing that
pops up when you press audible is what
the last book you've read i have a
couple of books that i've also like
bookmarked or some of them i've only
read halfway and it's a really easy to
use so sometimes if i get somewhere
early like i was meeting up friends for
dinner last night and i got there uh
early like 30 minutes early i could just
hit play so i'm sitting in the car so
it's just instead of just like scrolling
aimlessly on my phone when i'm going in
between places like if i have 10 minutes
here 15 minutes here all those little
times get to add up and it helps me
finish a book so i feel really
productive versus just like scrolling
endlessly and replying to all the bots
in my instagram and you can start off
where you left off too yeah and it just
remembers and it's like wow technology
thank you you're my bookmark yeah so i
love it and uh you get one book credit a
month so if you actually read that fast
because it takes me a couple months
sometimes then you can check out all
kinds of books and they're your one-stop
shop for your audio entertainment so
they have shows podcasts
originals in addition to the audiobooks
let audible help you discover new ways
to laugh be inspired or be entertained
new members can try it free for 30 days
visit audible.com off the record or text
off the record to 500 500 that's
audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500-500 to try audible for free for 30
days audible.com off the record i met
tiff our sophomore year and we had like
advisory together and like advisory was
like a home room where everybody would
like just do homework together and i
guess we got grouped off and i never met
her and i just started talking to her
and i just remember thinking like man
she's really cool it was like really
easy to chat with her and i was like but
i didn't really think much of it
but i was like oh like we have a really
good connection and then sure enough
slowly throughout the year we kind of
would just chat
and like i would talk to her at football
games or something like that and i just
remember thinking like man she's really
cool we laugh a lot it was just really
easy to talk to her compared to like
other girls
and then
we became friends
and we would just always hang out and i
i kind of i felt like i've always liked
her but i would always be really flirty
with her all the time but we were mostly
friends and we would just chat hang out
in denial with yourself like you you
like no you don't wanna like her for
some reason no i just think i just
wasn't really into like
getting in a relationship
like i would i felt like collecting
probably clearly this is yours no no no
because i felt like i had a lot of
different friend groups so i would like
hang out with a lot of different friend
groups and just chat over here because i
would just kind of float around i didn't
really have my own like friend group you
know what i mean have you been in a
relationship before no no that's why
yeah so but i wasn't looking i wasn't
looking to be in a relationship i just
was like yeah whatever but kind of as we
started hanging out more and we started
hanging out and like just
having classes with each other i was
like man i already like this chick i
thought like she was really cute and i
would like flirt with her and i would
once again i wasn't trying to be in a
relationship but i would always be very
like
forward with her i was like you know
when are we going to make out like i
would be a little pervert honestly
really yeah well that's your flirty
that's strong
i was like i was like yo like i would
say wild [ __ ] to her all the time and we
gonna do anal well like low-key
i would kind of say crazy [ __ ] just like
make her laugh what would she say she's
like oh you're stupid yeah no but like
she was super wholesome like she was a
super sweet like straight arrow
that's why i made her laugh yeah and i
just was like yo like i could just say
whatever and it's funny that she had a
sense of humor about it like she
wouldn't be weird yeah so i was like oh
cool and then we would hang out and um
i started dating that one chick well not
dating but i started talking about one
chick who like liked me and then i kind
of liked her throughout the process the
one that broke my heart yeah yeah and
she started dating some [ __ ] loser
so [ __ ] nerd you know what i mean she
was like uh tiff was yeah she dated some
guy from our rival high school and i was
like why are you even talking to the
dude this guy's a square and i'd be like
why you like him she's like he sings and
i was like what the [ __ ] like he sings
like what is that like i just would
always make fun of him you know and then
we would we would always see each other
with like
with each other singing with others or
whatever like that i would see her in
like a there was this thing called the
royal ball where people would uh
do like the rose parade and [ __ ] like
you would be people would try out to be
like the homecoming princess or some
[ __ ] right on the parade and we went to
this and she was there with her
boyfriend and i was there with a friend
and i just remember thinking like yo
this dude sucks bro i had to [ __ ]
chip a mushroom
yeah yeah and every time i would always
talk to a singer yeah i'd always see her
at a different dance and i'd always be
like yo like like once you come dance
with me like what the [ __ ] i'm like yo
[ __ ] your day let's come dance on me i
was like i was a [ __ ] i was a wild
boy i would say wild [ __ ] i think
they're called homewreckers i'm a
homewrecker yeah and she'd always be
like no like i'm i'm with i'm i'm
hanging out with this guy i was like
yeah whatever cool cool and then fast
forward like senior year
she was i think she had just broken up
with this dude and she was on the
homecoming court or something like that
and she asked me to be her date on the
homecoming court
and i was like whoa that's big actually
yeah that was her senior year yeah
but that was just like to go on the date
right yeah but that's turning up the
heat yeah yeah exactly and i was like
quit digging around i want that dick
already yeah and i was like yo i think
she likes me all right
but this is when it gets interesting
this is interesting so like we go on
i was like super nervous but i was like
all right cool this is gonna be fun
because we already had a really good
rapport we had a really good connection
and like she started like holding my
hand like we've never made all these
first moves yeah and then she would like
put her head on my shoulder and i was
like so she was doing all the work yeah
and i was thinking in my head i was like
i was like y'all i'ma [ __ ] kiss this
chick nick was wearing a dress she was
wearing a tongue
[Laughter]
she carried me through the threshold
yeah and then like can you tighten my
corset for me and i was like oh it's too
tight
so then and then and then she kind of
made all those moves because i was very
like i'm gonna let you do whatever right
so anyway
at the end of the night i'm driving home
and i'm like yo this is where i'm gonna
[ __ ] make my move yeah and i was like
all right cool don't [ __ ] this up you
got this
and then i'm waiting
i drop rocker at her house present bites
her yeah yeah so he pulls up
and i was like and i thought like
naturally we would kind of fall to kiss
and i gave her a hug and i was like hey
i had a really good time last night she
was like cool thank you thank you and
then we were like this right
and then i didn't i was like [ __ ] i
think i missed my opportunity
and then i go like this
i'll see you later and then like she
she's like she's like
and then she leaves like i don't i don't
think
i don't think she wanted a kiss bro like
really yeah she was holding her hand
yeah exactly exactly so i was like
and then she left and i was like oh [ __ ]
okay cool
i was like i don't i [ __ ] up i totally
[ __ ] up steve is pulling his [ __ ]
hair i can't believe he did this [ __ ] i
did this [ __ ] yeah and then emphasize i
just kissed you no and then she she left
and then the next day and then she was
the next day on monday right back in
school she was being kind of avoidant
and being really short and we would text
all the time bro we were texting she was
being super short and i was like yo what
the [ __ ] i was tripping right so then i
asked her i was like yo are you of
course i go are you mad at me
hey are you mad at me or something right
and then she's totally like nah i just i
don't know like
it was just kind of weird i don't know i
think i need some time
to think about this [ __ ] do you think
your kid's like at the dance and he's
like it's jesus
that would be so sick yeah and then so
and then i think she just was like she
didn't know what to do too like i think
it was more of like well she knew how to
do everything else yeah i don't know i
gotta have i'm actually i'm gonna have a
conversation with her man yeah you
should you should use your brother
confront her confront her
how did you guys get back together so
like it was kind of weird but then
slowly i would just be persistent i was
like yo when are we gonna talk blah blah
and then we slowly started like chatting
again but it was it was like it was like
a couple days you know it wasn't long at
all and then i thought dick was gonna
say and then i met this guy and he
looked like me but he's like he's like
he wasn't named me and he's like yo oh
man i mean i mean nick
you gotta like get it together with ma
that that daddy yo
you you guys are supposed to like get
together real soon
it gets on a skateboard and just flies
away i was like what's going on what's
that guy it's not tiff it's biff
he took out all my bullies in like four
minutes
did you tell him you can't take that
kind of rejection yeah i was like i
can't take it i know but so we started
talking again and because i'm a slow
build guy that's how i work right i'm a
slow build so then yeah i just [ __ ]
chip away i just kept chipping away and
eventually i was just very forward i
think what it was is that i wasn't
forward enough with her right in
retrospect actually as i'm telling the
story i'm realizing like oh she probably
want to be more forward like even from
day one
what's up she maybe thought you weren't
into her i don't know well you better
ask her and we're gonna need an update
so anyway so then i eventually go hey
let's go on like let's go out on a date
blah blah blah so we started we went
like ice skating and [ __ ] and then the
second time i asked her out
i was like okay i'm gonna ask her to be
my girlfriend right so then [ __ ] i was
like [ __ ] it like this is it this is
gonna be the girl
and then
i told her i was like hey i'm gonna
let's go to in and out after we ice
skating she's like okay
right so i i drive her to like i'm
clearly not going to where in and out
was supposed to be at the time and i'm
taking her up to the mountains and i go
to like this little like view aka
makeout point make out point and then i
just asked her to be my girlfriend and
then
that was it the rest is history and ever
since then what did she say she's like
she's like oh no
she's like she steps outside like let me
think about this steph's not the car no
she said yeah and then [ __ ] kids yeah
she was really happy about it but it was
like
it was i worked up to the point where i
knew i was like all right
for me i had to be like i really need to
know that she likes me likes me because
i was definitely confused after that all
that point but it took [ __ ] three
months you never explained yourself why
it got weird i think it was just like
she just felt uncomfortable and she was
unsure
like she felt weird that
like she liked me like i didn't know she
didn't know how to process it because
that was her first like real
relationship too and she was kind of
she i think she was she had a bad taste
her mouth after her last boyfriend
that little [ __ ] dude i still see him
to this day too oh you do yeah i still
see him do you do this to him every time
yeah sometimes he acts like he doesn't
see me at like a certain supermarket
that's where he works [ __ ] and like
he'll look at me and then walk away and
i'll be like hey man what's up
you know
and he'll walk back oh hey
nick what's up dude and i was like hey
how are you bro because i see him all
the time and he works with like my best
man like he works with the best man on
my wedding oh right so it's like i'm
like oh biff i said
i said two
[Laughter]
but that's so high school though
it's so high school all right this is
what we need to do you need to ask what
was going through his mind and then
we're gonna have a part three to this
where you come back with that
information and ryan tells his story
next okay and i hope there's no deaths
i can't wait for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you